the Seahawks are taking a ton of heat
after being seen celebrating with cigars
after the final game of the season
because it was also when their season
ended yikes but they had a reason
pictures surfaced of them after they
beat the Cardinals but missed the
playoffs and as you could imagine former
players and Seahawks media members more
pissed one reporter even called them out
for celebrating not making the playoffs
but Julian love the player in the pick
explained that the cigars were there to
celebrate the birth of his son who was
born on December 23rd 2023 and he wanted
to wait until the end of the season to
celebrate with the guys now for as
timing goes could he have waited to
celebrate off Seahawks grounds probably
but it does make a little more sense
given the context